hello and welcome to a live stream of
Dungey SLA my name is Jason Hara and I'm
not gonna move my laptop in fear of
messing up the HDMI connection that I'm
here live with a bunch of people at code
Smith's office in Venice say hello
alright and I'm gonna share my screen
and just infinite infinity of screen
okay so yeah my name is Jason Hara and
tonight we're gonna learn how to build a
tender a tender like carousel so this
app that you see on the right this evil
tinder you might see some faces or some
things that you recognize some evil
characters so we're gonna build this app
it has a like and note button we can say
yes or no and then it has swiping as
well so if we swipe left there's this
little nope animation that comes up or
if we swipe right it'll be the little
like and then when we let go we go to
the next character so that's what we're
gonna build before we get into it I want
to say thank you to our sponsors so I
hear it here where we're hosting tonight
is code Smith you're not familiar with
code Smith's definitely check them out
pit Smith CEO they are not a boot camp
they focused on programmers who
especially self-taught if you're like me
and self-taught and then you want to
kind of up your skills and go to that
next level it's like developing your
software engineering your programming
your machine learning skills that's all
things that they focus on so definitely
check out code Smith dot IO they have
offices obviously here in LA and in New
York and then Oxford University as well
and then my employer I'd like to thank
them is bateau B we're a JavaScript
consulting company we have a wide
variety of clients from small nonprofits
and startups to Fortune 500 companies
that we saw and we sign NDA's we're
thinking
we build apps for them we have a team of
developers I'm one of them and an
awesome user experience team so we
tackle design we tackle building
applications from both like the design
and the development so check out the
Jovi calm and that brings me to like why
we're here today and what I do so
excited I'm chasing I'm part of the poor
team that develops a bunch of
open-source detect for the Tovey that
includes can Janice jung jae seok etc so
we're going to use Kas today to kind of
give us the tools to build our
application and Kendra's is a
client-side JavaScript framework it has
its roots going back ten years ago and a
framework called JavaScript MVC so it's
been around a long time but it makes it
really easy from to build is simple web
widgets all the way up to scaling to
larger applications and this is how we
build absent but Toby
so it has three kind of main principles
and I make sure that my screen this is
large as it can be okay so basically the
the core concepts of Kas is you build
components and the components is a a tag
a custom element tag so when you put
that tag anywhere in HTML that that tag
gets upgraded into a custom element or
into a component it's rendered with a
view so you'll see between the tick
marks this is what we call I can stash
view who's seen like handlebars or
mustache before yeah okay so it's a very
it's a similar syntax where wherever you
have double curly braces like this that
means that that value is going to be
replaced with something dynamic so we've
got the double curlies and count and kin
sash also has a binding syntax we're
listening to events so this on :
we'll listen to click events
double-click Mouse just any Dom event
that you can think of you can put there
and then when that event happened
on the element then then a method fires
in the last part so that's so custom
elements are with tags they're rendered
with a view and then the third part is
that's backed by a view model so a view
model it's just a model for you like
you're providing whatever properties and
methods that you need in your view so in
this case we have account property that
starts off with an initial value or it's
a fault value of zero and then we have
an increment method so that when the
button is clicked it'll call this method
in the view model and we can put
whatever logic we went in there so in
this case we're just incrementing or
accounts and that's it this this is how
we builds like simple widgets this is
how we scale up to you entire web
applications that are built from these
principles that if you have custom
elements that are components that have a
view that are rendered with a view model
for all of the properties and actions
that's it any any questions comments
before you move on yeah yeah so view and
react in angular and Kenji is a number
like there's yeah there's so so when the
Tobi started ten years ago there was no
view or angular or ember or react so we
started developing our own framework and
from there it's grown into what we have
today which can't yes so yeah yeah
there's other companies that contribute
to can GS and other frameworks but were
the major contributor so and white like
the may be a little bit yeah and we can
definitely get into you like specific
stuff like what are the trade-offs and
and like why you would pick and
hopefully from just going through the
going through the building and
application today you'll get a feel for
like
what you like about this framework
hopefully it's all what you like about
this ring cool any other questions
no okay so take your laptops everyone's
connected to the internet go ahead and
go to canva.com
and on the left hand side that's a candy
SCA and Jas calm and then on the left
hand side you'll see a a guides link and
then under the recipes section there's a
tinder carousel when you click on that
you'll end up on this page you can also
search for it if you're feeling fancy
search for tinder it will come up
can I have up weighing that page and
everyone's on that page for the King
James calm and then guides and then
under the recipes section there's the
tender tender carousel everyone good oh
yeah yeah yeah we're in but do you have
another browser do you have Firefox or
Chrome installed you don't okay really
look here I mean that could be pretty
good yeah that that might be yeah if
you're able to generate a newer version
of like Chrome or Firefox and go from
there cool sounds good okay so basically
how tonight is gonna work is we're gonna
go through all of these steps of
building the app that I demoed bit a
little bit earlier so we'll we'll set
everyone up and then we'll go through
these steps of like showing a current
and next profile image adding the I
think it was a heart I can't remember
what is
the like button yeah the like button
will add the the X note button and make
those work will make the like sliding
and tracking Mouse events work will have
the overlays we're gonna do those all in
in steps so I'm gonna talk about the the
problem that we want to tackle the give
you everything you need to know to try
it out on your own and then I'm gonna
give you guys five or ten minutes for
each step to actually try it on your own
pack away see if you can get it working
and then we'll go over a solution
together and after that all right the
site has these really handy copy buttons
in the upper right of all of the code
examples so don't fret if you didn't
come up with a solution on your own it's
really easy to just like copy paste and
get up to speed so go down to the setup
section you can do that from like
clicking the nav or this map or just
scrolling down through the setup section
and you'll see and almost completely
blank code pen and click on the Edit on
code pen button in the upper right of
that so they'll open up code pen the
HTML field should be blank the CSS we're
not gonna worry about styles at all
that's just there for us to utilize so
I'm gonna collapse that but rjs me bump
this up J yes we're gonna write a lot of
jeaious in here so well what's pandadoc
cool everyone have their their code been
opened you don't have to sign up for
anything just open it I did away cool so
let's go through what the JavaScript
does it's fairly straightforward who has
seen the es6 import syntax before who
has seen this like import yeah so until
recently the best way to load scripts
was with a script tag and that put
something on the window and you start
using it which isn't great for
maintainability or modularity or what
have you
so in Kansas you can use the native
import statements this isn't running
through like webpack or steeled reyes or
any of the other funders it'll load this
file and then import this module out of
it so components is basically all we
need to build a canvas application so
we're gonna we're gonna make heavy use
of of components in it so the first
thing that I want to do is kind of
similar to what we had on the home page
I want us to create a components we're
gonna create an evil tinder custom
element and when that is in our HTML I
want it to render to render this HTML so
you might tell me okay well I can put
that HTML in there and then it's done
right we're gonna want to make this
dynamic weight like right now the
currents and the next it's all hardcore
coded in there so that's why we're gonna
want to have that as a component in our
JavaScript so what do we need to know
okay so we've been through some of this
already so we can use components and
we'll use component extends and we'll
set evil tender as the excuse me as the
tag so when we have you know brackets
evil tender in our HTML the component
will take over and then in our view we
want everything up here so I would make
heavy use of this copy button you can
copy copy that HTML and you're gonna
want to put it in your view and then
view model we don't need that yet
there's nothing dynamic yet but go ahead
and toss that in there because we're
gonna be adding properties and methods
and stuff I'm pretty soon so go ahead
take a couple minutes on your own to
create the evil tinder components that
has this HTML rendered as its view and
then we'll go over solution together in
a few minutes do you want to try
okay and always feel free to raise your
hands if you have any questions
throughout the night
didn't actually try and see it's that it
might just be two movies side by side or
like tacos together change of view oh
okay oh here we go
okay awesome
I think yeah it's not gonna look sorry
about that
who feels like they're coming to a
solution
they've got got it working got one two
three four five it's most people okay
cool let's let's go through a solution
together who wants to get me started
clicking give me step one or there step
one there's no it's no actual step one
yeah let's do it okay all right so what
are the three things which is evil
tinder all right mu sweet I'm gonna
totally copy-paste this over here
if you're ever frustrated with the
alignments in in the editor at least on
a Mac you can hold down the shift key
and then click to another another like
place in the document and then you can
tab everything all at once okay so we've
got our view and then what's our last
thing let's add that it's just gonna be
an empty object okay we don't have
anything rendered yet what's our last
step yeah so in our HTML we'll put evil
tinder
all right I'm gonna collapse this
because we we don't need this anymore or
all right so we've got our we've got our
custom element we've got our view it's
actually rendering engage this looks
good because questions comments anything
you guys want to talk about before we
move on to the next step oh cool
all right so if you okay so if you keep
scrolling down on the page you'll see
the the solution section I'm gonna just
add a habit I'm gonna copy paste this
every time just to make sure I have
exactly what's what's there so I'm gonna
I'll delete what's in the JavaScript and
paste in and then it's probably exactly
the same but to make sure we're naming
things the same okay next okay so we
want to show so right now in in our app
we have this thus current image in this
next image hard-coded we want to make
this dynamic so we want to have an array
of images these are all of the URLs to
the different characters that we have so
instead of having these hard-coded we
want to put this in our view model and
then show a current image and a next
image so our current image will just be
whatever is first in the array and then
the next image is what's next in the
array so what do we need to know okay so
we already actually talked about this a
little bit so when we have properties in
our view model those are made available
to us in our view so in this example we
add a profile property basically all of
the the keys and this objects are the
properties that we want to make
available so we have this profiles
property that's available to our view
and then this bit is Kandra has specific
so we're saying the default or the
initial value for this property is going
to be what's returned by this function
so this little bit of syntax is the like
is the like getter syntax in es5 es6 yes
yes well I I don't remember which which
spec this was added in so this is saying
okay this this default is a function
that returns returns an array so in this
case where we just have an abbreviated
version we just have the an array of a
couple of things and then the next thing
about that is the so in this example the
profiles in the view comes from the view
model and then there are helpers for
being able to like do stuff in the
template so we're not going to go
through all of the docs but there's
helpers like if in each and things to be
able to like do loops or your
conditionals or that sort of thing the
other question yeah so this so this view
model has all of the like properties and
actions that are made are made available
to our view and then so for properties
they basically have a like type
definition so this is kind of like
setting up what that property is gonna
be like so we have a this default getter
is basically whatever the initial value
is for the property there's a couple of
other we'll kind of get into a few other
things that we can put in this type
definition that's like getters and
setters and and that sort of thing but
to start off we're just gonna have this
default method does that make more sense
yeah images from there shouldn't be and
we uploaded all of these images to
github servers specifically because
their server is immense for putting
images you know wherever you want so
that's why there shouldn't
any issues with living things good
question yeah yeah okay so basically in
our stash templates wherever we have
curly braces or double curlies that's
where like stash is taking over and it's
going to do something special so like
here we have the double curlies and then
we're just printing a property value and
that's kind of the most simple case and
then second to that is whenever we have
the hash this means okay I'm calling
like a helper function that's that's
made available by the like templating
engine so there's a bunch of different
helpers like hash each hash if patched
just various things and we'll we'll go
through a few of these
does that make more sense sweet cool any
other questions before me okay so we've
talked about we the images that we want
to show we've talked about adding
something to our view model to make it
available to our view and there's so one
more kind of syntax that you can have in
your view model is this getter syntax so
this isn't specific to you
Kas if you've seen the getter syntax and
again yes 5 vs 6 I don't remember which
spec this is just saying okay I this is
a property name and then this is a like
getter function for that so whatever is
returned in this function is going to be
the value of that property so we could
have done the same thing up here where
this could have been like get profiles
and then just return the array it's
saying a similar idea so this is gonna
be helpful for us because you can
imagine there's a current profile you
might want to make a next profile and
then this is how you can get something
from the profiles array and
and return it as the salad so you can
create a like next profile property that
gets the like second thing cool any
questions before I let you loose no okay
take a few minutes try and make the let
me go back to the HTML try and make this
this print image and this next image
dynamic with stuff that you put in are
in the view model so you don't want to
have the hard-coded like image source
here you want to have that be some value
that you get from the view model again
please just put up your hands if you
have any questions I'm happy to explain
more
who feels like they're starting to come
to a little bit of a solution yeah yeah
alright we'll go through it together
then once they get me started where
where should I start from here okay I
sorry okay did we do the same for this
gun oh I'm gonna call this next profile
that image okay I like where this is
headed what's next yeah let's do it so
should we start with profiles or the
current profile and the next profile
togethers alright let's do that so we'll
do get current profile so this is a kind
of standard syntax Gitter so in here we
can return whatever we run we want who's
just got a line for me what should we
were trained so we'll need to define
this profile it's property property but
yeah so this is our profile it's like
get we'll do the same thing for next
profile so we'll have a getter for it
and then we'll return the stuff profile
that's one since that's the second thing
in the profiles array and what's our
last one it's the last little bit that
we need yeah so we could say like get
profiles and return this array so that's
one way of doing it what we showed in
the like what you need to know was a
little bit of a different syntax of
saying okay we're gonna have a profile
to property and then this object is what
defines what that property is like so in
here this syntax kind of gives us a lot
more options of what we can do so we
could have the same thing as the getter
syntax with a which I get method that
returns the array I think what we
actually want to do is just define a
default value which is gonna be the
array so the difference in like a
default versus get is that this is
saying the this is an initial value it's
not gonna change you can modify this
property but if you need an initial
value or it's a Fault value then here's
one for you whereas the guest is saying
any time you access this property here's
what you're here's what we're gonna
return okay so see if this actually
works so in the in the problem section
it says we can kind of play around with
the console to see if this like actually
made it time Amick right it looks the
same I guess we could one way we could
do it is we could remove stuff from here
and see if it updates correctly okay so
that's that's one way of testing it
another way is code pen makes console
available to us so in the bottom left
there's this console button you don't
have to do this you don't have to follow
along long
I want to show it so it has there's this
console button that pops open this
little section and then we can paste in
what we had before so this is saying
document doc pre-selector this is like a
native Dom API native browser API that
says I want to give you a CSS selector
and I want that I want a single element
that matches that selector I want the
first element that matches that selector
so we're getting our evil tinder custom
elements and then on it is a view model
property and then we've got all of the
data that's in our view model so the
same thing that's rendering the view is
in this view model property so we're
accessing profiles and then we can call
shift which I have a hard time in splice
the array methods shift is the one that
pops off the first thing from the the
first index of an array or zero index of
an array so when we run that in our
console that'll actually like modify our
view model which updates to be
automatically I'm gonna do that again do
that a couple times we're gonna write
code that does the same thing cool any
questions before we move on to probably
adding like and note buttons any
questions before we move on no cool
okay if you want you you can do the same
thing that I'm gonna do
every time under the solution there's
the copy button and I'm gonna replace
all of this I think it was I think it
was basically the same thing in a
different order but same code okay now
we're gonna add a like button okay so
when someone clicks on the like button
which is this this heart this green
heart button at the bottom we want to
console.log liked and then we want to
remove the first profile image the same
thing that we were doing in the console
earlier we want to remove the first
profile image so it comes off the stack
and then show the next one in the list
so what do we need to know well just
like the example on the home page we can
use on colon syntax to listen to
whatever events so we can listen for
click events on that like button and
then inside here is the method in the
view model that we want called so this
isn't going to like call that method as
the template is being rendered it'll
call it once once the button has been
clicked so in our view model we can
define a an action or a method like this
and this is just kind of standard syntax
for for defining a method so we can have
do something it can take arguments so
like in this example we're passing
advanced from the view into the view
model and then when that button is
clicked it will make the alert and then
the last thing shift shift is what
you're looking for to pop off the zero
index of something in your a that's it
go ahead and take a couple minutes any
questions before we break for half no
okay cool
so you want to make this you want to
make this like button actually like
who feels like they've come to a
solution a few hands then take another
minute go through a solution together
all right
who wants to get me started with a
solution what should i do first let's
see what do we want to call it I'll go
in like to profile okay so we've got our
our method inside here what do we want
to do yeah we do both
so we'll do a console.log I think all
cats liked and then there is star
profile up side shift so we haven't
quite gone over oh oh that was exciting
we're we're having a screen issues all
right there we go that's okay let me
switch back to not showing my face
sweets and then let's not have this be a
million times smaller
oh sorry guys oh that's sweet okay
all right I think we're back on track
I get this ring okay okay so one thing
we haven't like 100% talks about but now
it's as good of a time as ever so this
this inside the inside of like these
gutters and this action this always
refers to an instance of this view model
so essentially what canvas does is it
takes this view model object and it uses
it as
as like the base for creating new
instances of the v-model for each
component so in our app we only have the
one instance of we only have this like
one evil tinder but if we had multiple
evil Tinder's in here they would each
have their own instance of the view
model so if we swiped on I don't know if
I can actually show this so if we like
oh we not yet okay so if we like made
modifications and one components it
wouldn't affect together it's a new
instance of the view model for every
every like HTML custom elements that's
in the page so that's what this refers
to that's what the risks refers to
inside here so okay so last thing we
need to do is actually hook this up so
on our like button I'm gonna add the on
: click and we're not a call like
profile so now when we click on when we
click on the heart we've got the first
one disappearing and then in our console
we can open up the the code pen console
and we'll see lights lights lights for
every time let me clear that for every
time that we click on the light cool any
questions and comments nope
okay let's create a note button I'll
give you guys a minute or two and do
basically the same thing just hook up
the note button maybe add a console log
that says nope actually I'm gonna puppy
paste solution so we're all on the same
page yeah this one had its method called
like so go ahead and create a working
note button
where's there no button working sweet
let's make this one work
okay so just we'll have our nope method
let's say nope we're gonna do the same
this profile of shift we're not doing
anything special there we're just
removing the top one and then on our
disk button we're gonna say unclick nope
and call that method then when we open
the console we should see when we click
lights we've got lights and when we
click nope
we've got notes sweet any questions
all right now we're gonna make this more
interactive not just button clicks now
when we swipe on these images we're
actually going to move them left and
right so let's go through what we need
to know for that Oh actually I'm gonna
like always I'm gonna copy the solution
make sure we're all along the same page
sweet okay
so drag and move the profile to the left
and right so when as the user drags left
to right the image will essentially kind
of just move left and right we're not
gonna do we're gonna keep it simple
we're not gonna do like complete
tracking of like wherever your your
mouse or your finger moves we're just
gonna move moved horizontally we want it
working on desktop and mobile so if you
were to pull out your phone this would
actually like work on your on your iOS
or Android device and the element that
we want to move is the current one so
we're gonna cific li-like we
specifically want this div to be the
thing that we're moving back and forth
we don't want to move like anything else
in our in the Dom so what do we need to
know okay so the first thing is that the
way that we're gonna move it is just
with CSS so we're gonna assign a left
style essentially to the image to to
move it back and forth so essentially
this would be similar to if you oh that
is not readable that's also not readable
um maybe this okay so this is the same
as saying this this div that is that you
can kind of see on the right that it's
highlighting the current image so this
div is what we want to manipulate to
move back and forth so if we if we give
it a left of 100 pixels you can see that
it'll it'll jump that way and then as we
as we change this value that's how we
can
outfit image like being moving and then
essentially if we go into negative
values it's the same as like swiping
left so positive negative values are all
allowed here so we want to do this
except with JavaScript and we want to be
able to have that actually track where
the where that one else is moving so to
do that oh sorry
last thing is that so we can so in our
in our view model we can have like a
left property or how far we have moved
property and then render that in the in
the view with double curlies so just
like a normal HTML attributes and then
inside there will have a double curlies
for the v-model property so we'll do
that we'll define how far we have moved
as a number again the view model is just
whatever is to the right here is just
saying like a type definition so this is
a shorthand to say number or string or
any value or what have you the next
thing is that we're gonna need to listen
for when the when the current element
moves that current div when it moves so
canvas has this way of of listening for
events or let me take a step back okay
Jesus has a way of being letting your
code be notified when the custom element
has come alive or your sprint inserted
into the page so all of these view
models are like new unique instances and
when a new one is created for an element
that's in the page this connected
callback method is called on your view
model and it's given and you're given
the custom element so in our case this L
would be this L variable would be the
evil tender custom element so this
matches the custom elements spec so this
isn't basically candy s matches what is
what is specified in the custom
elements spec so connected callback lets
us know okay our element has been
inserted into the Dom which means we can
start like doing Dom related things so
we can get a reference to our to that
div to this where is it to this current
div by using the query selector method
that's on every HTML Dom element so
that's how we can get a reference to
current and then came just gives us a
way to listen to events and before I get
into the can GS part I want to talk
about I want to talk about events so for
years there were just desktop browsers
that had events like mouse over Mouse
out Mouse move mouse mouse all the
things right and then started having
mobile browsers and there was a
different API that was implemented that
were all touch events so instead of
mouse mouse events it was all touch
events and eventually most of the
browser's came to a consensus to
implement what's called the pointer
events API so this is this is a standard
API that essentially melds together the
Mouse and touch events and puts it into
pointer events so like Mouse down
there's a pointer down or mouse move
there is a pointer move of course not
all devices are going to fire all of the
same events right like there's four
stuff that would be related to hover you
don't have like a hover state in on
mobile right but for for things where
there are there is an analogy there's
pointer events every browser except one
has implemented the spec that one
browser is Safari it's not Internet
Explorer it's Safari actually I don't
know it's Internet Explorer version for
today
I know edge supports pointer events the
Safari on desktop and mobile they so far
they have refused to implement this way
so we can use what's called a polyfill
who's who's heard of the term
we filled before okay a few people so a
polyfill basically says okay I'm gonna
write JavaScript to mimic the same api's
that are native to a browser if they
were to implement those api's so in our
code pen I actually already set this up
so under settings you'll under jaw the
scripts I added this pep yes pointer
event I can't remember what the P stands
for it's a polyfill for for Safari so
that's already loaded if you pulled it
out longer on your phone on an iOS
device it would just work so we're gonna
be able to use these pointer events and
just not give any cares about safari
support so we can listen to these events
with some ap is that kangjae s provides
so this dot listen to is an API inside
of our view model that lets us provide
three things the object that we want to
listen to the events that we want to
listen that are being dispatched from
that object and then a callback Windows
events fire so in our case we want to
listen for we want to listen on the
current div whenever there's a pointer
down which is like a mouse down or a
touch down
I don't know if they event is actually
called touch down but we want to listen
to a pointer down event and then when
that happens we'll we'll have our code
we'll have a callback called we already
talked about the O the P stands for
polyfill pointer events polyfill that's
peteus there's a couple of the
attributes that we need so you noticed
earlier when I was when I was dragging
with our code as is like the browser
will be helpful and be like oh you're
like dragging in the image let me give
you that to you so you can put it
somewhere else or whatever we want to we
do not want the browser to do that so
there's a couple of attributes that we
can that we can add so there's a touch
action on on mobile devices and then
draggable draggable false is what we can
use for
top browsers to say don't give me the
default dragging behavior let us handle
it on our own and then the so inside
that we we already talked about like
listening to pointer down the vents so
inside of our callback we have access to
this events variable that's passed to
our callback event has the super useful
property of clients X which is the
current position of the pointer device
mouse or finger or what have you so this
is what we can use to see where the
mouse is currently so that's gonna be
super helpful because when there's a
pointer down events we can grab the
event client X and have that be our
starting place and then when we receive
any other pointer events for the for the
movement of the mouse that's how we can
calculate the Delta between our starting
place and then wherever the user
currently as which is how we can do the
left positioning essentially so this
will be so in pointer down we can listen
for that to find out the like initial
value and then we can listen to pointer
move to when the like mouse is actually
moving or your finger is actually moving
across the screen this is a little bit
different so pointer move so here we're
listening on documents anyone want to
guess why we would listen on document
instead of currents it will be for a
while and then eventually you're gonna
be moving off of it and or you would
otherwise be moving off of where it is
initially positioned and then you lose
track of those events so that's why we
want to listen anywhere in our in the
document body we want to listen for a
pointer news and it gives us access to
that same client on the events okay
so what would happen if you put it back
on if the mouse started somewhere
outside of the pictures frame yeah which
I think for us it matters that if you
start dragging and then if you drag off
of where the image would be positions
then you're not going to get those
events fired so that's why it matters in
our case that was a lot that we just
went over so I want to take a quick
recap so what we what we want to do
right now is we want to add that style
that left style so that we can move the
move the current image left or right and
then we want to set up this property in
our view model we want to set up our
connected callback so that we can add
these this stuff listen to callbacks and
we want to listen to pointer down as our
start pointer move for as the user is
moving and there's a couple of HTML
attributes that you'll need to add to
the image to make sure that you don't
get the like default track behavior it's
gonna be real awkward because at this
point there's no like pointer up or
whatever the event is for like letting
go so when you have this working it's
just gonna keep on like after pointer
down it's just gonna keep on following
your mouse that's okay we're gonna well
we'll do that in the next step
any questions for you back on your own
cool will take longer for this well
we'll take like 5 or 10 minutes please
feel free to raise your hands if you
have questions
we have counsel mark just yes that for
the regular AAR's the first users how do
you think they connect person one to be
the profile we have ours here that's the
whole interval ten profiles array this
is what brings hmm
so worries
it's through yeah so to connect the two
people in terms of like what actually
happens when you're inspecting I'm sure
so they I'm guessing that they're
loading the so they've got their like
back ins API service for actually
getting all of the profiles it wouldn't
surprise me if a lot of basic mechanics
of fetching a list of like 10 or 20 like
profiles is similar to how like we have
our arepa files and then as people are
swiping they're doing the same
conveniently removed from their list of
like local profiles that it's a nice
house and then you know when a person
likes your first legs left or right and
they're sending that they're making API
calls so we put a console on fit they'd
be making an API call to say okay this
person liked or didn't like and it's
been a while since I'm you sender but if
I remember correctly it'll immediately
tell you if it's a match yep okay so
they could do that a couple different
ways where maybe after the Swiper is
when they make an API call to know if it
was a match or not or maybe they already
know maybe they already have it in
client's that if they swipe right it'll
be a match or if they spike no it just
keeps on going and then it would so then
they would probably a different API sort
of messaging part where it's okay both
the Wicked Witch and Swiper and so then
rip them access to me Louie's map yeah
whatever yeah exactly that would be my
guess
Belsize questions like yeah I'm sorry
question on my name is certainly
connected call like that that's like a
reserve by the spring so what if it
doesn't
fifties on the scene so yeah you could
you could actually we're just remember
so this this is this is so you could
have all right we'll start going through
a solution together once they get me
start what should we do first
yeah let's do it
what am i changing yeah so what was this
called how far we moved that's fine I'll
run with this all right so we okay so we
add the style property to the current
the
the class current div so we'll have this
how far we moved property in our view
model let's go ahead and add that so at
the bottom I'm just gonna check things
on to the bottom so at the bottom we're
gonna have how far we moved and it's a
number we won't do anything with that
okay what's next what should we do next
yeah let's do that because otherwise
we're not gonna actually be able to drag
so touch action
it stuck touch action none and then
draggable pulse okay sweet what's next
yeah so now so like with draggable false
now when we drag we don't get the like
default browser behavior if we remove
the trackable rats that's where it like
it'll show the dragged image for us yeah
let's do it
okay so we're gonna have a connected and
connected call back we're given the
element which is the evil tender custom
elements so in here we're gonna want to
listen for the pointer down and the
pointer move vents so let's say bits
don't listen to Oh
first we're gonna need the current
elements so we'll say current is l dot
query selector basically this is saying
like we could do document dot query
selector and then this would give us all
of the dot or the first dot current in
the entire document but we want it
specifically for our elements for our
custom elements so if there were
multiple instances of it in the page
then we'd get the right one so we're
going to be current and then we're gonna
listen to we want to list
on current for the pointer down and then
we have our callback so when this is
called that's when the user actually
presses down okay what should we do next
yeah okay so we could do like what how
do we want to do this okay so we'll have
start X and then we'll assign startx to
claim X does that right way next okay
cool okay so now we have when the user
presses down what's next yeah let's do
that so I'm gonna help me paste this
move around okay so now we have you want
to listen to a pointer move and then
this is where we can set the how far
removed property so how far we moved is
the current is the current client X
minus our starting - okay so that should
update as we as we move is that it is
that everything we need
Hey yeah that's working and as expected
we can't let go or just forever forever
holding on to it okay cool was there
anything else that we needed a dad I
think that was it yeah whereas
about what we just did questions okay so
they're a really good sign I really that
song
okay I'm gonna as always i'm gonna go
down to the solution i'm gonna copy and
replace everything in here just to make
sure everything's consistently named
okay the next thing that we're gonna do
is we want to show the like in the no go
i start do is when the user goes more
than 100 pixels to the right that means
they're swiping right and we want to
show the like animation and then on the
other side if we go negative 100 pixels
then we want to show the the note
animation so we'll start off with just
the like and the way we do do this is we
already have the like CSS and the
styling and I'm just gonna hack this in
here real quick this is not what you're
gonna do nice somewhere though okay so
we're gonna we have this result and then
if we if we have it with liking if we
have it with the liking class that means
that it'll show up I think so I need to
say thank you okay there we go thank you
good catch okay so when the did the
result div has liking it'll show the
like when it has nope what is the class
we'll get to that later
no ping is it no ping yeah it won't open
there we go okay so obviously we want
that to be dynamic so we only want to
show we only want to have this liking
class there when they're actually liking
so we can view that with the hash if
syntax
so this says if the this value in your B
model is truthy if it's true or some
true like value then go ahead and add
this class and then we can define a
property for for liking for determining
if we've moved more than 100 pixels give
you guys a minute to do this on your own
while you're at it go ahead and do the
know ping as well liking and open
who has that a solution for liking and
opeing oh yeah we'll take a another
[Music]
all right who wants to get me started
with a solution go for it yeah yeah we
can call it an F segment what are we
gonna double up on liking okay so when
liking is true we'll have we'll add this
liking class which means I should have
minimized this earlier which means down
here we can have our liking we'll add it
with the rest of the getters so we can
have our liking gutter and then here
we'll return if what's our property mean
how far we nodes what do we want to
return this dot how far we moved is
greater greater than equal to 100 yeah
cool we'll do the same thing for no pain
like unknowing and it's gonna be what
you did 100 is that right okay cool
and then we'll add our no pink class up
here too so we've got liking and we've
got no pink all right let's give this a
spin there we go beautiful and then if
we go to the right we still need to add
that that down or listening and
listening for up not down but listening
for up but when we move where's the
boundary when we move far enough we've
got those cool any questions comments
well I'm gonna do the same thing as as
always I'm going
I'm actually gonna go down so these were
two different sections gonna go past and
open make sure that's everything up
today okay
now we're gonna get to you when we
release our mouse we want to let go and
either if we've swiped far enough right
then we want to then we want to log
liking and if creeps swipes far enough
to the left then we want a log or no
ping so and then do nothing if we
haven't dragged more than a hundred
pixels in either direction okay so if we
drag far enough in either direction the
wool lycra nope and then the last little
bit is we want to make sure that we
reset things so that when the user has
another pointer down that it's brand-new
and we're not maintaining any of the
state from the previous mousing around
so what do we need to know okay so we've
got our pointer up event for listening
for Mouse up and then our last thing is
we have this listens to and then the
opposite of opposite of that is stopped
listening so this is a can jsapi that
says I want to remove the event
listeners from a particular object or I
want to remove a specific event listener
from a specific object so when we in our
code right now we've got this listened
to on the documents as we're moving
around but we don't need that listener
anymore when the mouse has gone up right
so when it's down that's when we care
about the pointer move the vents but as
soon as they go up we don't care how
they're moving their mouse around the
screen because it shouldn't be moving
anything right we only care if they
started at a pointer down so so that's
the that's the last little bit so that
leaves a lot of logic up to you guys for
what should go in the callback for a
pointer up and when you call stop
so I'll leave you to it for for a few
minutes yep if you have questions please
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
feels like they're coming up with a
solution you guys want another minute oh
yeah please do yeah
[Music]
all right who wants to get me started on
a solution what should i do first
yeah okay so I'm gonna steal some of
this code okay so I'm gonna listen to
pointer up on not the document
we're sorry not current on the document
for the same reason that we listen to
pointer booth wherever I'm gonna listen
to pointer up wherever they've ended up
on the document okay what's next
yeah so I'm just gonna steal that code
and then update it here so we're gonna
update this dot how far we have moved
with the current client X minus the
starting X and then what that does is
when we haven't gotten into candy-asses
observables and how like all of this
stuff works what when you set this
property anything that depends on this
property's value will be rerun and
updated to have the new value so when we
call this not how far we have moved and
give it a new value anything anything
that that anything that depends on it is
gonna be updated so like in nope methods
no but inside here inside of our liking
getter in our no ping gutter this will
because this value changed these getters
will be rerun and those values will be
updated so that's kind of how we get all
of the dynamic parts of candy is is that
it figures out everything that your code
on all of the observables and then when
one of them changes it only updates the
things that are listening to it so when
how far we have moved changes that
doesn't mean that the getter for current
profile and next profile are going to be
run that's only going to happen when
something inside it like this stop
profiles changes so given that we've
updated this what can we do now yeah so
we could write out what is it this how
far we have moved is greater than equal
to 100 that would mean that we would do
we would say is it liking or get like
like okay and then we could do if that
is less than or equal to negative 100
and then do the stock nope nope okay so
we could do that but since the since
this has updated everything that depends
on it we can just do this liking and
this saw no pain because those those
properties in our B model are
automatically going to be updated with
the latest so we can we can reuse stuff
that's in our if you model whenever we
want okay so and then our our L case is
essentially we do nothing we we don't
like or nope if neither of those
conditions are true we're fast they're
second-to-last I guess yeah
well reset yeah we'll kind of reset
everything so will will say how far we
moved zero and then we'll stop listening
as well so this stopped listening to the
documents so the both the pointer up and
the pointer moves listen
are going to be torn down when we call
stop listening it's going to tear down
to all of the document related listeners
that we set up and it'll keep this one
because the element is still alive when
this thing is you don't have to manually
with this like listen to syntax with can
GS usually you'd have to call like add
eventlistener and then remove event
listener to tear everything down
correctly like if the elements is
removed from the page with canvases like
this dot listen to you when this
component gets torn down it'll remove
all of the listeners on that component
and then any of its children as well so
that's why we don't have to do any stop
listening to print will it work can I
let them it might be too small
not quite I just sorry I just removed
everything that I just done all right
let's go through this so yes you're
right I had to find pointer up outside
of the pointer down but I actually
needed it inside of the inside a pointer
down so so it would be updated correctly
cool so this should work correctly now
there we go
sweet any questions comments
yeah yeah so the mark-up up here the if
liking and if no pain is that what
you're referring to pretty similar
because
the if stash helper is basically serving
the same purpose as like if JavaScript
statements the kind of big difference is
that in our template this is being
rendered with our view model so we could
do this start liking and this not
knowing it's redundant because our
current context is the view model anyway
and otherwise they're the same and then
down here the the connected callback
gets with the view model instance as the
this or as the current scope or context
which is why we can do like this dot
liking in this town open because yeah
which define like yep um see this code
would be optimized because you put all
of those in the JavaScript yeah so
that's actually a really good point so
one of the things that we advocate for
is building unit testable view models
that have all of your logics so your
view like our view is pretty
straightforward in that it has minimal
conditionals and it's basically just
printing out values and then listening
to events so it's not as as complex our
view model kind of contains all of that
logic so we can create a new instance of
the view model in our unit test and then
test like okay if I set these properties
that it does certain things or you can
call different methods and it's just
it's easier to have that kind of in the
view model and testing it versus
rendering a whole component and then you
know simulating different states and
events and that sort of thing
yeah
so mote most of them have like every
component has its own will have its own
file we usually like when you're
actually building apps you break this
off the template into a different file
so you get like syntax highlighting and
stuff like that so yeah we we heavily
promote having like a folder for each
component that has the JavaScript and
the template and its tests and like a
demo page and kind of all of the stuff
related to a single component yeah cool
any other questions yeah so can the type
definitions have a few different ways
that you can define values so we we
talked about default let's say we wanted
to have this be asynchronous so we could
the API for that is basically that our
dip function is given the last value
that it was set to and then a function
for updating that value so we could do
whatever like Ajax request to get the
data and then you know resolves with
that data and then this this property
would be updated with that yep and you
can go from really simple like I should
have said like you know just using the
fetch API to do something like that or
use whatever utility that you want to
can GS provides stuff for modeling your
data similar to like how a view model
models data
excuse me modeling the server data and
then doing fancy things for like when if
you define an endpoint that is rest
lights then kimsey-house can do special
things that's like alright I can assume
that when I do a get request it'll be a
list of this and when I have that the
instances will be created into like real
model objects that have whatever
properties that you define and just go
down the rabbit hole but the most simple
thing would be like in a getter to have
fetch and then get the data good
question
cool any others all right we'll wrap up
there's one more step when we you'll
notice that there's a bunch of
characters here but we eventually to get
to the end and it's just a broken image
right because eventually we get to we
gets to current profile but there's
there's no there's nothing in profiles
left right so let's fix that
so what do you need to know page there's
a URL for an empty profile and then you
basically want to define that property
and then use that when you've run out of
images give you guys a couple minutes
mortgage resolution
[Music]
yeah so authentication is interesting
because there's a lot of different parts
to it right because not most mostly in
an app you have like a single session
for the logged in user so you could you
could create a like a view model
essentially or a model object that
represents the user or their session and
then on that you could have all of the
requests for like signing in or doing
whatever you need to to authenticate
them and then that that object you would
probably pass around in your application
because they'd probably need lots of
components that would want access to the
current users information so we didn't
get into it at all today but let me
expand this a little bit because we only
talked about like having this one custom
elements essentially when you build
congest applications it's just many and
many of these custom elements and you
pass data between them so the syntax is
like HTML where you could say like on
evil tender if I wanted to pass in the
session I could say session colon from
and then the session objects that's in
the like outer context whatever is
rendering that component would provide
the session so like if this let's say
this is gonna be recursive but let's say
like in this view we had another
components then in the view model we
could have session
defined and then we'd be able to pass
that to a child's component for them to
be able to like see the users info or
what have you
yep exactly
yeah so most applications yes and most
of the time you have like one like
top-level app component that has usually
its routing info and session info kind
of gets stored in that top-level app
component a good question let's go
through a solution the ones to get me
started
[Music]
yeah let's do it
how are we changing them so actually
yeah what did you do it wasn't okay yeah
I see there or which is scarier than you
thought
so I'm guessing you had something like
assigning a profile to a variable and
then if profile terminates and then
otherwise like return infinity profile
something like that it might tell ya
space of what you were trying yeah okay
cool yeah which totally works you
assign assign it to a variable check if
it is true thee and otherwise return
another property
the shorter syntax that the guide shows
is saying return this or return that
value which in JavaScript it'll be if
this is a false e value then it'll fall
through to the other side of the port
condition so it's just a shorter way of
doing that same if L syntax so we can do
those for both of it for both current
profile and next profile and then I'm
just gonna steal this this definition oh
that's not right
so we can define our empty profile
that's an object at his image now when
we get to the bottom of this we should
see there we go when we see our empty
profile sweet any any questions or
comments before we go all right I want
to thank everyone who is here obviously
you guys asked a lot of great questions
so thank you for coming everyone who's
watching on the live stream or watching
afterwards thanks for watching and we'll
be back in a month we do one of these
every like five or six weeks and we're
always building new apps for these so if
there's something that you're interested
in like in learning how to build let me
know either in the Dungey SLA meetup
group
leave a comment there or talk to me
afterwards or message me I'll meet it so
thanks and we'll see you next month bye
hey I'm Vijay thanks for coming to the
meetup today I'm the organizer for
JavaScript la I wanted to just
personally thank you for watching this
video if you found it useful I'd love
for you to subscribe to our channel
we're slowly but surely making lots of
little video content for you guys to
enjoy and soak up especially if you want
to get better at programming I'd love
for you to be on our slack channel to
over 800 users the link is right here
jeaious join jsj oin if you forget it's
really simple you have questions for
this meetup or you know questions you
didn't get to ask or because you
couldn't make it we'd love to have you
just posted in our slack group so if
you're a newbie don't worry it's a good
place to go there's a lot of great
engineers all connected around la in
Orange County so I hope to see you there